well earlier this morning I spoke with
Robert's son Walt chairman of the
National Transportation Safety Board
which is investigating this crash let me
begin by asking you about the driver
there are reports that he ran through a
stop sign before crashing has that been
confirmed well good morning and before I
begin I really want to offer our
sincerest condolences to all of those
affected by this horrific tragedy as far
as the actual details of the crash we
are just beginning our actual
investigation certainly it does appear
from the physical evidence that somebody
ran through that stop sign but we want
to understand why that happened and as
we mentioned this intersection is
notoriously dangerous residents here
have been talking about how concerned
they were about it what will the
investigation lead you to look into with
regards to the intersection we will
certainly go back and look at prior
accidents prior crashes that may have
occurred at this intersection that's one
of the many things that we will look at
and as far as the driver himself what
are the first things you're going to be
looking at are you going to be looking
at cell phone records for example yeah
we always look at cell phone records so
we're going to go back and see if he if
he may have been talking on the phone we
will look at his medical records we will
look at the toxicology results his prior
driving records everything like that we
will be carefully looking at and of
course as we mentioned 18 people lost
their lives in that limousine there are
safety concerns about seatbelts and
regulations required in limousines what
can you tell us about that well we
certainly want to look at the oversight
and make sure that the see if the
oversight is is sufficient for seatbelts
we do know that seatbelts can be very
very helpful
in a crash
we want to see if they were born what
are the laws now as they come to
limousines and who should be wearing
seatbelts well I think everyone should
be wearing seatbelts that's the first
thing we want to look at the exact laws
they're certain as we know for a car in
every state except for New Hampshire
it's required to wear seatbelts for a
regular passenger vehicle however when
you get into other modes of
transportation like motor coaches
they're not lost for that as far as
limousines I'm not sure exactly what the
requirements are at this time Robert's
son Walter a tragic morning to be
speaking with you we appreciate your
time thank you so much thank you good
morning